I was reminding of her of her worth
because as a feminist we're all
feminists here right we all believe in
women empowerment I'm reminding of her
her of her worth are you a feminist sure
you're not I believe in feminine
empowerment and I think feminine
empowerment is yes I do and feminine
empowerment is in modesty modesty is
empowering for for females only believe
taking your clothes off for men on
Instagram is not empowering it's
empowering when you say no man but my
husband can see my body that is female
empowerment and I was reminding her of
that I was reminding ing her of her ripe
age and her intellect and there was no
need for that